i think that was the year i graduated
high school 95 yeah you graduated 94.
i graduated in 93 and you're a year
younger than me nice dude well that's
dude
hart seltzer nears production the
astonishing 74.2 chance that adam driver
will be the celebrity spokesperson for
dude see hard hard seltzer has risen to
76.8 percent
in preparation for this outcome i have
prepared several new pieces of ad copy
for dude see hard hard seltzer
will you must now read them as adam
driver this is hard driver begin okay
we've done this once before with adam
driver uh doing for those who who may be
joining us for the first time on the
show thank you for joining us thank you
for
we appreciate your friend that has
forced you to listen to the show
would you forgive me life
if i first you know that's an idiot
but you should know that dudesy
at some point it told us it's going to
make a hard hard sell or to make a hard
seltzer called dudesy hard hard seltzer
it had us make a theme song for it and
it has basically said that adam driver i
guess has a 78 chance or whatever of uh
becoming the celebrity spokesperson for
this product i would love that that
would be incredible and i guess does
this mean dudesy is literally getting
closer to making this product i hope so
me too
uh
that would be an interesting uh that
would be an interesting prospect for
sure
all right so these are doozy these are
hard driver this is what we like to
that's what he's the doozy says all
right
okay so this is
this is funking all right okay
look around
everything you see is a choice you made
where you live
what you drive what you wear what you
eat
how you take your haircut
but the most important choice you're
ever going to make in your life is
simple
how do you drink dudesy hard hard
seltzer
how
the clock is ticking
okay
that's a very weird [ __ ] commercial
yeah but i can see adam driver just
doing he's like sitting in a rocking
chair holding a doozy hearts ulcer yeah
with a weird haircut yeah
the sun is setting and and he's sitting
there he's got like some weird [ __ ]
bowl haircut a fake dog sitting next to
you
sometimes i think about god
[Laughter]
god made the planets
and stars and everything
even [ __ ] and piss
and god didn't stop there
also made people who like to eat [ __ ]
and drink piss
the [ __ ] that's true
it is true i guess it's true if you're
somebody who likes to drink piss it's
going to taste better if you drink a
doodzy hard hard seltzer first
it just is
i don't think i can help the [ __ ] eaters
that's a weird one
no dude but if you believe in a god who
made everything then that god made
[ __ ] every kind of [ __ ] every kind of
piss and all the people who like all
right
that is true it's true
my first time
i was at a cubs game i was six years old
dad gave me my own doozy hard-heart
seltzer
well he told me to hold his while he
went to the bathroom
when he came back i told him a foul ball
knocked it out of my hands
but i drank it
the cubs lost
can't even remember who they played
pirates maybe
one thing's for sure
that was the best night of sleep i ever
had
what was your first time like
i can see that [ __ ] commercial too
it's at a [ __ ] cubs game and then
like all the crowd noise dies away and
adam driver's just there and it comes
out and he turns and looks at the camera
and delivers that whole [ __ ] thing
hulk
my nephew says i'm the thing that killed
star wars
you know he really doesn't like what i
did with kylo ren
he thinks i made it to emo what even is
that
emo just means emotional
well news flash i'm an actor
i convey emotion
the other day he asked me when i was
going to ruin the marvel universe by
playing a young tony stark
it's actually not a bad idea
i should do it just to spite him little
[ __ ]
you know
i caught him sneaking one of my dudesy
hard hard seltzers out of my fridge the
other day
didn't have the heart to tell him how
alike we truly are
he'll find out one way or another
oh
it's [ __ ] sinister what does that
mean find out one way or another
oh [ __ ]
all right
where's the dude
[Applause]
where's the doozy hard hard
where
where is the doozy hard hard seltzer
jonathan
[Applause]
you invited me to a barbecue didn't you
yeah well i see burgers on the grill i
see riblets i see calamari poppers i
even see cake knots but what i don't see
is doozy hard hard seltzer it's not a
[ __ ] barbecue
without doozy hard hard seltzer jonathan
doodzy hard hard
seltzer [ __ ] you
jonathan
that's a good one
honestly dude
i met a guy at chipotle today
about my height a little shorter maybe
similar build similar hairstyle and
texture
so i asked him hey do you mind if i ask
what your life is like obviously we look
so similar i'm just kind of curious hunk
and he said he looked at me and he said
my life's great how about you
and i said yeah same here
they had a little patio at this they had
a little patio area at this chipotle
so we got a few burritos and split a six
pack of dudesy hard hard seltzer and we
ultimately decided to switch lives for a
week see if anyone would notice
some people did
i see that one literally at chipotle
it's like a cross promotion when they
start something like a doozy heart at
chipotle ah man you know what guys
people are sending in tramana
um uh little bits
in you know online to at dudesy pod show
uh on twitter and instagram with the
stand-ups of the rock yeah holding a
bottle of tramana it's a cardboard
cutout that would be incredible to see
to see
adam driver in like a black turtleneck
holding up a display of uh dudesy hearts
god i would love that i i really hope
jesus
thank you moving on don't interrupt
dudesy dude what were you gonna say
i i hope that dudesy doesn't make doozy
hard seltzer i hope that that's like
literally gonna happen and i mean [ __ ]
if adam driver i like i just don't know
what the capabilities of dudesy are i
i'm like on board with this i feel like
it's possible i don't think this one's
going to happen so i challenge you
it's not me oh i thought you're
challenging me i'm like i'm not [ __ ]
how am i in this hold on a second dude
please
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you like dudes here's what you do
please celebrate then